jonathan vient de malmedy en belgique il
a parcouru 1500 kilomètres pour arriver
à medica dans son camion de l'eau des
couches du lait des jouets des peluches
j'avais déjà revenir faire en tête
l'idée de faire quelque chose peut-être
pas de venir d'un coup mais de
participer de manière active
c'était une évidence donc voilà et comme
j'ai trois enfants voilà c'était
spécialement pour les enfants qu'on a
fait le
avant de partir il est allé voir les
commerçants de sa ville tout le monde
s'est mobilisé pour lui remplir son
camion benne chocolatier de la commune
j'habite qui nous a préparé je pense
presque de nuit des petits ballotins de
chocolat spécialement pour les enfants
donc ils à tours balle et sa femme aussi
ils ont été géniaux jonathan ne
connaissais personne en arrivant très
vite il a rencontré jérémie et nicolas
des français venus des vosges
arrivé quelques heures avant en voiture
avec 4 100 couvertures et des
médicaments comment les autorités ici
c'est terrible et regarde là on a fait
franco belge
on a mis le drapeau a péché dans ce
magnifique christophe et dans la vie
pompiers professionnels il vient de nice
en france il a posé des congés et
direction la frontière
écrit et joué
en criant
tu un peu humaniste aussi voilà il ya
des gens cruels d'un côté il faut qu'on
mette la balance un peu de l'autre côté
ils sont presque gêné un petit peu de
tout ce qu'on leur apporte et tout ça
ils sont très courtois et franchement ça
fait ça fait plaisir de voir un petit
peu quelques sourires et cet élan de
solidarité n'est pas près de s'arrêter
chaque jour des dizaines et des dizaines
de bénévoles arrivent du monde entier
via leurs propres moyens espérons aider
à leur échelle les réfugiés ukrainien